- If you heard the name of this show,
you've heard of our
first guest. (chuckles)
She sold over 25 million albums.
- [Audience Member] Whoo!
- She's won-
Yes!
She's won "The Voice" four times.
She's the winner of two Sports Emmys.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Yeah!
- (chuckles) She does it all.
(audience clapping)
(Taraji laughs)
She's a mother of two beautiful children,
and I'm using her dressing
room today. (chuckles)
So, let's say hi to Kelly Clarkson.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
- What's up!
- You know, I started to show up looking
like that today, Kelly, but,
(audience laughing)
I didn't wanna do you like that.
- [Audience Member] Look!
- Sometimes women don't
rise, Taraji. (chuckles)
Sometimes-
- Hey, look!
- Sometimes we fall. (laughs)
(Taraji laughs)
- But you got up, 'cause you're
on the screen. (chuckles)
- Look, I thought,
I thought we were done with quarantining.
- [Taraji] Right.
- And I'm so tired. (laughs)
- That's so. (laughs)
- I broke a nail.
- [Taraji] Oh no!
- I'm so broken.
This is me broken.
- Oh no! (laughs)
- All my make-up's expired.
America, this is what I look like.
You're welcome.
- Well, let me say this to you, Kelly.
This is the first time I've
left my house since Christmas.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
Oh, you got guests.
You got a couple of people
wanna say hi to you.
Y'all,
y'all.
- [Kelly] Hi.
- Hi Kelly.
(Taraji laughs)
- We miss ya.
(Taraji clapping)
- Come back, come back. (laughs)
- So, is there anyone
else you wanna talk to?
- Oh my God. What's-
Hey Roman, are you wearing
a superhero costume?
- No, I went, I went, you
know, "Saved By The Bell'.
You weren't here.
- "Saved By The Bell", Zack attack!
- Yeah, it is, he's healed me. (laughs)
- I miss y'all.
I'm so sorry. I'm not even sick.
It's so weird.
- I know.
Anyway, we're keeping it safe and
that's it.
- It's okay,
if you have wine in that mug,
we'll pretend it's coffee.
(Roman laughs)
(laughs) It's happy
hour somewhere! (laughs)
- You can't tell what's in it.
- Oh, you know what? I love this.
I saw you tweeted recently,
"Our third night in a
row to watch Encanto, ha!
My kids are obsessed. I
don't mind, it's so good."
So how's that going, huh?
Are you still watching Encanto?
- It is good, but like,
okay, you might get this.
When I watch a movie with my children
it's like watching three movies, okay?
We're watching Encanto, I'll
show you my broken nail.
- Right. (laughs)
Encanto and then you're
listening to my son
who always leaves, like, mid-movie
and just starts singing the soundtrack.
So, you have the movie going
and he's singing the soundtrack,
and then you have River,
who literally, just right
after the line is said,
she just repeats, like she's
memorizing dialogue for a play.
(Taraji laughs)
She just says the lines
as they're, I'm like, "Baby, I'm here."
Like, she'll look at me and
she'll be like, "She just said-"
and I'm like, "I know,
'cause we are both here watching it, so?"
But literally it's like
watching three movies.
We've seen it so much,
but it's so cute.
- Yeah.
- We've seen that in Ghostbusters.
It's that, or "Ghostbusters,
The Afterlife," the new one.
- I love it.
We've seen that a lot, but
once I put them to bed,
I have, you can tell,
I'm having a rough time,
if I just go to one of my classic shows,
that I like really need to tell,
like, if you catch me watching
"Pillow Talk" by Doris Day,
it's a dark moment I'm having.
(Taraji clapping)
(audience laughing)
Yeah.
(Taraji laughing)
Yup, that's where I
just, like, or "Castle,"
I've been watching reruns of "Castle."
I just went, and he doesn't
exist, that character
doesn't exist, it's a lie.
(Taraji laughing)
That man is not out there.
- (laughs) No, no Kelly, no.
- No.
- Kelly, come back!
- The entertainment is a lot.
- Come back into the light!
Come back into the light, Kelly!
(Kelly and Taraji laughing)
- I love it, I love it!
- Look, I know what it's like
when the kids start to get to you, right?
So, can I give you some advice?
Can I give you some advice?
- Yes!
You know, kids do
anything for French fries.
Have you tried that yet?
- Have you met Remi?
My son is a French fry.
(Taraji laughs)
- He is a French fry!
- He only eats beige.
(Taraji laughing)
(Taraji clapping)
French fries is his food group.
That's all the food groups.
- That's it?
He likes French fries. That's it.
(Taraji laughs)
- How old is he?
- Five.
Yeah. That's,
French fries and tater tots
and chicken nuggets, right?
I can imagine.
- Yes. I can't him to
a chicken nugget, no.
- No?
- He's now,
and this is the funniest thing ever,
'cause his dad is a rancher,
but, like, he is, kind
of, against meat. (laughs)
- Hey look, I get it.
- 'Cause he found out
that you kill the animal,
and he is like, he'll look at me,
and he'll be like, "Is this an animal?"
And I'll be like,
(Taraji laughs)
"Well yeah, it's chicken."
And he is like, "Oh no."
(audience laughing)
- Well, tell him I'm not
eating meat this week either.
Let's talk about this new project girl.
It sounds amazing. Tell us about it.
- I'm so excited actually,
'cause I didn't know when
we'd be able to, like,
talk about it but apparently I can now,
(Taraji laughs)
So, it's called
American Song Contest,
and I've been talking to the producers
of "The Voice" and "Eurovision"
for a minute about it.
I've been obsessed with "Eurovision".
So, when I went overseas, like, years ago,
you know, after winning "Idol",
I noticed, like, there
was this huge competition,
and I never heard of it before,
and it's called "Eurovision,"
and it was amazing.
And I thought it was so cool
'cause all the territories
get represented.
So, they're finally bringing
it over to the States,
and it's called American
Song Contest, ASC,
and it's really cool because I feel like
I think everybody could agree,
we're pretty divided, like, as a nation,
and it's really cool,
'cause all 50 states,
there's five US territories,
and then,
DC, our nation's capital,
everybody gets represented.
So, like, there's a person
representing every state,
every part and they all
enter in this competition.
And the cool thing about it too,
is that it's original songs,
and as a songwriter, I
think that's awesome.
- Oh, yes.
- 'Cause it's, like,
a different, you know, like,
there's a lot of shows
out there, you know,
that have competitions with like,
you know, singing or artists or whatever,
and it's really cool 'cause
the best song wins out;
and I'm co-hosting with Snoop Dogg.
- Ay! (claps hands)
- We got to
work together on "The Voice".
I love it! I'm so excited!
- (laughs) I love it!
We worked together on "The
Voice". It was so fun.
- Yeah, he's great. He's great.
You know, I know him from
baby boy, years, years ago
but he's still a really
dear friend of mine.
- Oh, my god.
He's incredible.
You're gonna have a good time.
That's not even gonna be work! (laughs)
- Oh, my god, I know.
That's why I was like, they asked me,
and I'm like," First of
all, I'm like such a nerd,
I'm so excited about the show,
so, all right, I'll do that."
(Taraji laughs)
And it was just exciting,
'cause I liked working with Snoop Dogg.
So, that was, I'd already worked with him,
so, that I think that'll
be really cool too.
This is probably gonna be
what I'm gonna wear for that too, so-
- That's good. It's all good.
(audience laughing)
You'll be beautiful. (laughs)
- Just keepin' it real all the time.
What are you doing? What are you up to?
- Well, I can finally say
that I will be filming the new version
of "Color Purple", the film, the feature.
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
- What!
- And I,
I will be playing Shug Avery.
Shug Avery's coming to town!
Hide your husband, honey!(laughs)
(Taraji clapping)
(Kelly laughing)
- I'm so excited, I'm so
excited, I'm so excited. (laughs)
- Oh, my gosh! That's really awesome!
- Yes.
- You just, like,
totally one-upped me!
It's fine.
- It's-
No, never Kelly! I can never!
You have sports Emmys, pfft.
(audience laughing)
(Taraji laughing)
- Apparently, they just hand 'em out.
- (laughs) Look, I hear
you doing construction
on your house and I'm about to start.
How is that going?
(audience laughing)
(Taraji laughing)
(Taraji clapping)
Drink your coffee! Wink, wink. (laughs)
- So,
it's like, here's the thing, it looks like
when people come to my house,
it looks like I have "Dexter"
kill rooms everywhere.
(Taraji laughing)
Like, there's,
look, yeah-
- Oh, my god, look at that.
- Renovations are not fun, but
they have to be done.
- Yeah, they do. I'm about to start.
I was just, I don't know,
I was hoping to hear some happy news,
but anyway, we bonded over our
love of Christmas last time.
Like, so, do you have
any Christmas ornaments
and things still around the house?
(Taraji laughing)
(audience laughing)
Drink your coffee! (laughs)
I have
not, look,
it's busy.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
There's a lot going on,
and so, I have not had time to,
I have all my stuff up.
- Oh wow.
That's okay.
- That was taken today.
They asked me,
they were like, "Do you have
your Christmas stuff up?"
And I was like, "Don't judge me,
yes, I do."
(Taraji laughs)
- Look,
look, I couldn't get the right containers,
and so, I finally,
they're on their way
and I'm gonna put it up,
but, you know what, I've decided
I'm probably gonna keep the tree up,
and I'm just gonna do
a different holidays,
like Valentine's Day,
I'm gonna be that crazy person, you know?
- You gotta, right?
You gotta, just change the colors,
just put pink for Valentine's,
you know, if it's Easter,
- Yes!
- put pastel colors.
- Easter. Yeah.
I won't judge you then. (laughs)
- I don't, you know what?
Judge away America,
I'm used to it.
- (laughs) That's right.
That's I love you, do what's
good for you! (laughs)
Look, I have to get to
the rest of the show.
The Irwins are here and
I have a great story
about teens using music
to help their peers
cope with stress.
Anything you want me to ask our guests?
- Hey, I love the latter,
the last thing you just talked about.
- Me too, me too.
- That's how
I started writing actually,
'cause I had a problem with emoting,
and my mom actually
told me to start writing
and use music as my outlet.
That is such a,
that's such a beautiful thing.
Like, you can have nothing in common
but like you can have music
and it's so powerful, so, I
love that you're doing that.
- Absolutely.
I think it's beautiful what
these young guys are doing.
I can't wait to meet them.
(audience clapping)
I can't.
- Well, hopefully they dressed up.
I'm just sitting here,
- Yeah. (laughs)
- in my robe brought to
you by Chrissy Teigen.
Thank you girl!
(Taraji and Kelly laughing)
- Well, Kelly is always
good to see you, honey.
Okay? Good to see you.
- All right, bye Taraji.
- Take care.
- Thank you so much.
- Yes, mama, stay safe! (lips smacking)